on retrouve tout de suite delphine des
shows du thar maîtresse de conférences
en sciences politiques à l'université de
grenoble alpes et membre du du centre
d'études sur la sécurité internationale
et les coopérations européennes merci
d'être d'être avec nous un mot forcément
d'abord sur l'image le symbole ces deux
étapes qui ont été choisis par le chef
de l'état français par hasard forcément
oui tout à fait merci beaucoup de me
laisser la parole les tops de la
roumanie elle était assez évidente étant
donné que la france a fondu à une partie
de son bataillon de chasseurs alpins
pour dans le cas de la présence à vent
s'est renforcé de l'otan également 500
soldats français en roumanie donc ça
paraissait assez évident que le
président à aller saluer et la visite en
moldavie à la toune également un sens
diplomatique très important puisqu'elle
vient finalement faire suite à la visite
à à l'elysée de la présidente moldave le
mois dernier pour laquelle le président
avait déjà annoncé que la france
soutenait en fait la moldavie et étaient
très conscients des menaces qui pouvait
peser sur ce pays on a un sentiment en
tout cas vu de ici qu'il faut aller
rassurer ces pays qui sont en première
ligne finalement
alors tout à fait je crois que ce rôle
de réassurance il est d'autant plus
important que la france a actuellement
la présidence française de l'union
européenne jusqu'à la fin du mois et que
la commission examine cette semaine
vendredi précisément les demandes
d'adhésion à la fois de l'ukraine mais
aussi de la géorgie et de la moldavie et
je crois que c'est d'autant plus
important en tant que président l'union
européenne un exercice que le président
français se rendent sur place puisque la
moldavie à une coopération importante
avec l'union européenne depuis plusieurs
années depuis l'accord d'association de
2014 notamment et la moldavie bénéficier
aussi depuis ce printemps de
renforcement du soutien financier de
mise en place par l'union européenne
dans le cadre de l'accueil de très
nombreux réfugiés ukrainien engendrés
par par la guerre en ukraine voilà la
moldavie peut être un peu plus inquiète
que d'autres états frontaliers avec avec
l'ukraine du fait de sa province
séparatiste de cet enjeu on parle
régulièrement de la transnistrie
ici c'est un lieu clé dans cette dans
cette guerre qui est en cours à
l'ukraine en ukraine
alors tout à fait cette province de la
transnistrie elle rappelle en fait
beaucoup ce qui se passe dans les
provinces séparatistes craignent and
c'est à dire qu'on a des les populations
russophones qui sont séparatistes qui
sont soutenus par la russie et le
président avait exprimé justement mois
de mai lors de la visite de la
présidente de la république moldave à
paris à la fois son soutien à la
moldavie et et son inquiétude face à un
scénario qui pourrait se reproduire en
moldavie comme cela a été le cas en
ukraine et c'est un souci que partage en
fait l'ensemble de l'union européenne on
parle beaucoup sécurité c'est un étang
la houle et les budgets consacrés à la
défense était plutôt revu à la baisse
ces dernières années on voit bien que la
tendance est complètement al'inverse ans
on parlait tout à l'heure du salon de
l'armement qui s'est ouvert ce lundi il
y aussi cette rencontre aujourd'hui à
bruxelles réunion des ministres de la
défense de l'otan qu'ils sont censés
faire quoi préparer le prochain sommet
de l'otan de madrid alors effectivement
cette rencontre des ministres de la
défense à bruxelles aujourd'hui elles
disent à préparer le sommet de l'otan à
madrid à la fin du mois qui va être un
sommet vraiment important pour
l'alliance atlantique puisqu'il sera
l'occasion d'adopter un nouveau concept
stratégique qui est en fait la feuille
de route stratégique de l'otan pour les
années à venir donc l'objectif c'est de
jeter les bases de la stratégie de
l'otan à l'horizon 2030 et c'est
important de rappeler que le dernier
concept stratégique date de 2010 donc on
voit bien qu'on est là désormais dans un
cadre qui est dépassée qui a été
dépassée des genres 2014 avec l'annexion
de la crimée qui l'est plus encore
aujourd'hui dont qui nécessitent
finalement que l'otan réfléchissent aux
prochaines de grandes problématiques
qu'elle va avoir à traiter
entendriez solberg le patron de l'otan
il s'est exprimé hier et encore de
nouveau
ce matin il semblerait que ce sommet de
l'otan va aboutir sur l'annoncé d'une
série de mesures en soutien en aide à
l'ukraine c'est vrai que c'est son
cloche qui est complètement différent de
l'autre côté en ukraine on s'inquiète
beaucoup de des lenteurs en termes de
livraisons d'armes
alors je pense qu'effectivement il faut
bien faire la part des choses entre les
annonces d'un côté et les regards la
progression des choses sur le terrain
puisque même dans le cas de l'union
européenne par exemple qui a annoncé à
nouveau des livraisons d'armes de plus
en plus lourde et massive il faut bien
voir qu'entre l'annoncent politique qui
est fait et à la concrétisation de
l'annoncé par les états membres qui
doivent dans beaucoup de cas passer les
commandes auprès de fournisseurs
d'armement réceptionner ses commandes et
pouvoir ensuite les acheminer il se
passe en fait facilement plusieurs
semaines voire plusieurs mois
merci beaucoup delphine des shows du tas
merci d'avoir été notre invité du jour
sur cette question de sécurité
internationales la coopération
européenne à l'heure où emmanuel macron
donc poursuit sa tournée mini tournée à
l'est de l'europe qu'il conduira
peut-être dans les prochains jours à qui
et voilà